Thousands gather outside Hungary's state broadcaster
in Budapest.
They're here because of this:
Opposition MPs being thrown out of Hungary's
state broadcaster building…
They had wanted to read a list of demands
on national television; demands linked to
a week of escalating street demonstrations.
Night after night, protestors have returned
to the streets -- there were around 10,000
over the weekend.
It is a very good TV-channel for fairy tales.
They don't broadcast the kind of story that
I would show my children in the future.
Unions and opposition groups organised demonstrations
against a new labour law, recently approved
by Prime Minister Victor Orban’s large parliamentary
majority.
The law - dubbed by critics as the ‘slave
law’ - allows employers to ask staff to
do 400 hours of overtime per year, and delay
payment for it by up to three months.
Demonstrators are unhappy with the labour
law... and with the direction Hungary is going.
We don't want to go back to the communist
times.
What we are experiencing now in Hungary, wasn't
seen during communism; this level of oppression
and corruption.
Something must be done.
This cannot go on.
Prime Minister Victor Orban -- and his policies
-- are very popular amongst Hungarians.
Yet, these protests show that there is a sizeable
and vocal section of Hungarian society that
opposes him.
It's the biggest and most visible challenge
yet to what critics - at home and abroad - see
as Orban's slide towards authoritarian rule.